i owe a lot to this person uh
i did research with them back in grad
school
and it's opened my eyes up to
a lot of statistical insight programming
insight
um his books have been amazing uh i will
consider in fact i have one of his books
sitting back there it is no i don't know
his book it's sitting somewhere else i
take that back i did not have his book i
have a book inspired by his work back
there somewhere in this house i have a
number of his books
his books have been amazing i've learned
so much i always recommend it to people
um
he is a great statistician and a great
teacher
so i am excited to
welcome to the stage
andrew
it is a pleasure to speak with you all
people who are using statistics and
using r and statistical software um not
just because you're taking a required
class and you want to get a degree to do
something but because you're actually
using it so i don't always have don't
always have this opportunity um
this talk i guess that it started um
about
15 or 20 years ago when i was in a taxi
going to the airport
the driver had on some religious
stations some channel i had never
listened to on the radio and it was some
preacher who was going on about how you
are a sinner you have to recognize that
you're a sinner only by recognizing that
you're a sinner will you be saved and
come to jesus and it was a come to jesus
moment for me not not literally jesus
but i recognized
that this was right that as
as researchers as practitioners we are
all sinners i mean we we always do
everything wrong it's it's obvious that
you do everything wrong because
you have a better understanding of
statistics now than you did last year
right or the year ago so last even if
now you're doing everything fine last
year or two two years ago you were
certainly doing things wrong um
and we make mistakes all the time
and
we are like
we never do anything right we we are
sinners and to be saved we have to
recognize this i was all excited when i
got home i i talked to my wife i said
look this is i'm gonna tell my students
this like you were all sinners this is
inspiration to me and and she said you
can't do that and i said why not and she
said you can't like be religious in in
class and i'm like yeah but i don't
literally like you know jesus just a guy
right you know like she said no but then
you're making fun of them and that's not
gonna say no i'm not making fun of them
i really believe that so so no i can't
do that so i can't tell my my class this
but i can tell you um
i
so i wanted to talk about all sorts of
mistakes that that i've made um
and what you're supposed to get out of
this
is well maybe some statistical insight
here and there um in the details of
these stories
but what i really want you to do is
inspire
yourself um
inspire you to come to terms with your
own mistakes and to learn from them like
you are you have to personally
you have it within yourself to become a
better data analyst a better data
scientist statistician program or
whatever it is
but if you
you're tying your hands behind your back
if you don't learn from your own
mistakes so the challenges are going to
be there they're kind of three
challenges so the first is to
get your work out there
so that people can point out the
mistakes
and then the second thing is for you to
understand what you did wrong and then
the third thing is for you to figure out
what went wrong in your process that
that led to the mistake
um
and let me i can tell you a story like
of of what not to do um
that somebody else did it's always
easier to tell stories about other
people making mistakes we we call those
finement stories when you tell a story
about someone else doing something wrong
and then you say how great you are so i
can tell you a feynman story first
before getting to my own errors so a few
years ago there was a group at harvard i
guess they're still around they
they they do this survey called the
electoral creating something they call
the it's called the electoral integrity
project i believe and
they survey experts about uh and ask
some questions about all the countries
in the world and then they give each
country a score of its electoral
integrity um
high score is good and low score is bad
and they make maps every year and they
get into the newspapers
and
um
one year they got a little bit too much
publicity because they did a spin-off
project where they did the same thing
for the 50 states where they had experts
evaluate different aspects it created a
combined score so the experts evaluated
different aspects of electoral democracy
in each state and then they created a
score the report came out and one of the
people involved was a professor at a
university in north carolina who
released to the news
that north carolina was less democratic
than north korea
and that got a lot of
uncritical press followed by some
critical press
and people wondering um well if your
measure says that maybe the problem is
is with the measure and i think it
turned out they they had like there are
there were six people who were asked
about korea and they they they gave it i
i'm not exactly sure what happened
except i think that they were kind of
grading korea on a curve like they were
like i mean maybe korea doesn't have any
gerrymandering at all i don't know it
doesn't matter right because they only
have one party but
they
i think that they may have been like
saying well korea's not as bad as you
think like i'm not sure
after this came out the people who did
the index defended themselves and they
removed north korea from the data set
well that's a good idea to remove north
korea from a data set but let's just say
like
if you notice
well like to be kind of new york about
it here so if you notice like some
rodent poop
on your rug the solution is yes you
should throw away the rodent poop but
you might want to actually also find out
where the rat is right
so they they didn't do that they
they just
kind of defended themselves oh we have a
very good measure this is what everybody
does we know we're doing
all that stuff um oh yeah why are you
complaining about north korea we took it
out of the data set
but they didn't really address the
problem with the process
um so now let me tell you some stories
of my own errors
a few years ago
uh
my colleagues and i wrote a book called
red state blue state rich state poor
state which had to do with how rich and
poor americans vote in different states
um
richer states such as new york and
california favor the democrats
lower income states such as west
virginia and north dakota favor the
republicans
however within any state richer voters
tend to support republicans not
democrats so this is the whole point of
our our book we we had this idea which
we actually did we had that site i guess
this is an r conference right so we had
this idea of a plot a graph we called
the super plot which was a graph showing
the relationship the probability of
voting republican as a function of
income
for a rich state connecticut a
middle-income state ohio
and a poor state mississippi and what
you find was what we found was that in
connecticut there was no relationship
between income and voting rich
connecticutions and poor connecticutions
vote the same way
in ohio there's a moderate relationship
in mississippi rich mississippians vote
much more
republican than poor mississippians so
that was the super plot
uh i made a lot of graphs like this we
made graphs of the different states uh
in 2008
after the election or maybe it was even
even before with pre-election polls we
made these maps showing
how the election would have gone if only
poor people middle-income people or rich
people had voted and you'd see and you
see that in 2008 obama won of course but
among poor people it would have been a
major landslide winning i think 46
states
if if the election had just been among
rich people according to our analysis
obama would have actually lost to john
mccain
um
and the maps got a lot of attention i
was very happy like people saw the maps
and and they they resonate with people
so i kept making maps for a while like
like i guess like a pigeon you know
trying to get more attention and so it
works i did more of it
people were interested we showed people
some of these graphs and people want to
know about white people
how do white people vote um
so
something like 75 80 of the survey
respondents are white so it's easy
enough to do we just redid our analysis
just getting rid of all of the
non-whites and making graphs for just
the white people
um
and made the new set of maps how did
white people vote i posted those and
then the next day after i posted them i
just got blasted
on the internet
um
and just like
this person was so rude
uh it's like saying i didn't know what i
was doing
he made mistakes himself he said that i
didn't use election results in my graphs
and i did use election results and he
said that i i should have used exit
polls instead of pre-election polls but
exit polls have a lot of problems and he
got so many things wrong but he also
had some very good criticisms of my
graphs because he went into some
specific states and he said
some of these maps don't make sense
like you say that mccain was winning
whites of this income group but this
doesn't make sense given what i've seen
the exit poll and you say this and this
doesn't make sense and
he was right like there there were
problems
um
and you can kind of see the problem
because i did one analysis of all the
voters and another analysis of just
white voters but like what would happen
like if
because they're two separate analyses
there's no reason that they'll be
coherent right and so like and so you
can get what if you've got something
where like
more white voters like take a state like
new hampshire
uh where most of the voters almost all
the voters are white
you can end up with something where you
estimate more than a hundred percent of
the white voters vote for a certain
candidate like it the numbers don't even
have to add up
so i i would realize what we should
really be doing is modeling vote by
income state and ethnicity so it's a
three-way model it's tricky though
because you don't have a lot of survey
respondents who aren't white so required
works i worked with my colleague yay
gitza and it took a few months and we
built a model with three-way
interactions and it was
was complicated to build like we but we
did it and then we we posted the new
maps uh there were a couple of other
things that we did to make things better
our first map was just use red for the
states that went for obama and blue for
the ones who went for mccain we switched
to a shading where we had going from
bright red to gray in the middle to
light blue to bro
to bright blue at the extreme so that
way you could tell that some
some states were less sure than others
and then we went back to the specifics
and we saw we addressed the comments of
the the online critic
and then finally then we stepped back
and made line plots so you know graphics
is what we often think a lot about like
one thing that makes is one thing we
love about r
um
there's something i i've called the
click through solution which is you have
the pretty graph which might be the map
you click on it and then you get these
line plots which show all the data which
show all the details which can show
estimates in raw data and then you click
again and you can get a spreadsheet with
the raw data and the code and you can do
what you want well i can't say we have a
click through there but conceptually
that's what we did that we went back to
understand things better we went back to
certain graphs which might be less
popular like with readers of the
newspaper but give us more information
so
to get to the main theme return to the
theme of the talk
i was successful in getting those graphs
out there getting the attention was good
because people saw i had problems the
same with those electoral integrity
project people it was good for them that
they got the attention because then
people pointed out that they had a
mistake right if you don't get yourself
out there no one will find your mistake
this is not just for academic work even
within your company it's a matter of
getting more eyes on it like reaching
people who care so these
there are a lot of people who care about
elections and you wanna and and they
help me out then the second thing was to
figure out what had gone wrong in my
process and then the third was to go
back and address the specific
criticisms with which we did um the
other thing was it was all kind of
remote like i at no point did i
talk
or email with the people who made the
criticisms i mean it just didn't happen
like i had it online they had it online
it went back and forth
it would have been fine to have talked
with them but it wasn't necessary either
wasn't a
personal thing
um
okay uh
second my second mistake is a slightly
different one um
back in 1994 colleague and i wrote a
paper called enhancing democracy through
legislative redistricting
now redistricting is the polite word and
gerrymandering is the root word
and as you've perhaps heard like our
democracy is being threatened by
gerrymandering
districts are drawn in such a way that
um
a party can be in the minority can
literally like lose election after
election after election in the state but
maintain a majority in the legislature
so it's a
it's it's a real problem
we wrote this paper
saying it wasn't really a problem
which which i think was wrong and and so
let me
let me give a little bit of background
to that um
the background was that from the 1950s
we wrote our paper in 1994 our paper
analyzed data from the 70s and the 80s
from the 1950s through the 1980s the
united states
was characterized by
increasing political polarization
and
fewer close elections
uh less what we call in political
science less electoral responsiveness so
what was happening was that there was a
concern a political concern and what and
what social scientists called puzzles so
the political concern was that we were
um
that the united states was having
the
politic
people are
communicating on this thing wait wait a
second i have to stop for a second
am i am i supposed to stop they're like
signaling or something
okay they're okay um
the
the political concern was that we're
having fewer competitive elections um
the system was less responsive to the
voters and we were having political
polarization and gridlock this was back
in the 1980s we're already worried about
political polarization um
and the puzzle was why did this occur
and one possible explanation was
gerrymandering so maybe the reason why
we're having um there's all this
polarization and elections that i mean
let me just continue for a moment when
you have a bunch of when you have very
few close elections that means that the
primary becomes more important and the
general election becomes less important
and so who who goes to congress you get
more extremists in congress because
um
monitors
all right let me step back if if if
elections are closer then you'll have
more moderates in congress because the
extremists will get thrown out but when
you don't have when you don't have close
elections once someone's in they can
kind of stay in forever parties can
nominate extremists knowing that in
in these unbalanced districts they'll be
able to win elections with with anybody
um so this was a concern and
one potential explanation of this was
gerrymandering so maybe the reason why
we don't have close elections is because
the politicians are drawing the
districts so that they won't be close
we found that wasn't the case so we did
an empirical analysis based on state
legislatures
from
in the 1970s and 1980s and we found that
after redistricting
elections became more competitive not
less competitive
which actually makes some sense because
when there's redistricting incumbents
retire
leaving open seats
so
we argued that redistricting had been
good for democracy not bad for democracy
which i think was like accurate at the
time now some things have happened since
1994 when our paper came out so one
thing is we have better data on better
computers and like programs like r and
everything and basically more people can
draw district plans now in it's less
there's less of a barrier to entry which
in particular means instead of it means
that ideologues can draw district plans
the second thing is we have even more
political polarization which means it's
easier to predict how people are going
to vote
and
if it's easier to predict how people are
going to vote locally then you can make
more effective gerrymanders because you
know where what people are going to do
the third thing is there's increased
polarization which means
it's easier for
state legislators to pass extreme
gerrymanders in the past if you tried
something too extreme maybe the party
wouldn't go for it maybe moderates in
the party would say this isn't fair
maybe there'd be a grouping of the two
parties that would stop it but nowadays
like
the parties are so separated the
majority party can kind of do what they
want
uh the next thing is that incumbency
advantage has declined meaning the fact
that fewer incumbents run after
redistricting is less of a does not
shake things up as much and finally as
you might have heard there's less
judicial scrutiny so in the past we even
wrote this in our paper the most extreme
gerrymanders wouldn't happen because the
legislators were afraid that it would
get thrown out in court but now the
court will like accept just about
anything
so
what i want to say is i was wrong
i don't think we were wrong in our data
analysis of the 1970s and 1980s but i
think to give a title like enhancing
democracy
we should have emphasized that our
results were historically contingent
so what we really should have said was
in current conditions redistricting
enhances democracy however
if there are no breaks on redistricting
if redistricters become too powerful
if there's more polarization
it will things could get much worse
and
we didn't right so i guess i learned
something from that example too which is
like slightly different because it
wasn't a problem with my statistical
model but i realized that
like
what it's very important
like we think about statistical
inference all the time
uh going from the data to your inference
but what about applying that into the
real world right so you might be working
at a company and you might be doing a b
tests and you might find something some
treatment doesn't matter which is kind
of like what we found well maybe the
treatment doesn't matter now but maybe
it could matter in another situation so
i think you have to think about the
domain of applicability of your findings
and we didn't so that was that was a
mistake
um
my third example
uh
is also well this one's also related to
polygon voting so
another paper from back in the 90s
we were we did research studying
changes in public opinion during
election campaigns and the question was
why do public opinion polls vary so much
when elections are predictable and we
had various examples of
past elections where
um one presidential elections where one
candidate would go up or down in the
polls uh and
seemed like the political professionals
realized that this wasn't so meaningful
but public opinion was changing so it
was a challenge like it's a very
interesting question how is it that
public opinion changes so much like how
come like as a political scientist i can
predict how people are going to vote but
people don't seem to know how they
themselves are going to vote it's a
little bit weird so we we talked about
different hypotheses in our paper
but i'm not going to talk about all that
what i want to focus on here
was one little bit of our paper where we
looked at something called the
convention bounce
and that is that when
um a party holds a nominating convention
for the president
usually
that party that candidate jumps by five
to five to ten points in the polls
so
that's happened almost every election
uh that candidates poll better after the
convention than before the convention
and we're used to that i mean we
everybody knows it and everybody expects
it but it was a funny thing
i used to give talks about this paper
and i would say
who are these voters like let's suppose
five percent of the voters shift so
that's saying that five percent of the
voters five percent of the people are
like well i was gonna vote for the
democrat
but then i saw this republican
convention and it was like a bunch of
speeches a bunch of really boring
speeches i probably didn't watch some
celebrities
uh a bunch of like pictures of drunken
conventioners with balloons and so i've
decided i'm gonna switch to the
republicans
well that's kind of weird right or maybe
maybe five percent the other way the
democratic convention like who are these
people who have this political view
that's changeable conventions are
conventional they tell you that they're
going to come and they happen there's
not a lot of surprises and even if
conventions sometimes do have surprises
the nature of surprises is that
sometimes they're positive and sometimes
they're negative right like that's like
it's like the stock market or whatever
right like it might be good news or it
might be bad news but you know the
convention is coming
so it's
election after election the convention
happens and then five percent or ten
percent of the people say hey
i'm stunned i'm gonna switch like who
are these people it seemed really weird
and we talked a lot about that in our
paper
so
it turns out we were kind of wrong
that
actually
i think what's happening is
during the convention fires up the
supporters of a party
and after that they're more likely to
respond to surveys
so we call it differential non-response
and it's not just the conventions it's a
positive feedback mechanism by which
when
um
when a k when there's good news about a
candidate
some people might switch to support that
candidate but their supporters are going
to be more likely to respond
so you get this phenomenon where good
news a little bit of good news shows up
as a lot of good news in the polls
because you're getting all these
respondents joining in more people
joining and then bad news it might not
change anybody's vote intention but it
reduces your supporters chance of
responding
now you might say at this point like who
cares like if people are more likely to
respond to a poll maybe they're more
likely to vote and so like
isn't that good to get good news get
your supporters fired up well sure but
like the response the voter turnout rate
is about sixty percent for presidential
elections the survey response rate is
something like ten percent five percent
whatever most people don't resp so
in the survey response rate is very
volatile if you can increase the number
of democrats who respond to a poll that
does not necessarily correspond to
increasing all having all these more
people going up voting
so
i found out about this in in a funny way
because back in 2012 i was working with
some friends at microsoft research and
they had this idea of doing a survey
using the xbox video game platform and i
was like sure go do it so i help them
with their statistical analysis because
xbox players are not representative of
the general population of voters right
so they they did some and we did some
statistical analysis then the the cool
thing about this this survey was that
they had data every day for 45 straight
days during the campaign so it wasn't
like the gallup poll or whatever polling
people once a month
um they could see and they also knew
they they also knew the stated party
identification and previous vote
of of these voters of the survey
respondents and what they saw was that
on the days that the republican
candidate mitt romney was doing better
in the polls he was always doing better
he was always getting more they're
getting more republicans responding and
when he was doing worse they're getting
fewer republicans responding and when
you adjust for partisanship it it fix it
it it reduces these swings by about half
or more
and i saw this and i'm like oh come on i
don't buy this like no way really like
really and then
like well i think they were they were
right then it turned out this was in
2013 our paper finally appeared in 2016.
then it turned out people have been
writing about this in 2012 and i just
hadn't realized so a bunch of people the
political scientists doug rivers some
bloggers
nate silver had written about it like a
bunch of people now
i'm not saying
like okay i think our work was valuable
like there's a difference between people
speculating and using one or two surveys
and doing a very careful analysis which
is what we did but the point i want to
make is is not that and
okay i can't ca
it's not that oh they scooped me
whatever but that when this xbox thing
came out in 2013 when i saw that i was
surprised right
so i obviously had something wrong in my
mind if i was shocked by this thing that
other people had already been been
talking about i
so i i don't know what general lesson to
make of this
actually like i i think i just was like
just haven't thought about this
um
so
let me switch uh to a kind of
positive message
um
so
i'll if okay i wouldn't say raise your
hand if you've ever done something at
work that's like new and great like yeah
yeah okay like and now raise your hand
keep your hand up if you did something
that was new and great and then the
other people at work were like uh
like really like uh
okay yeah yeah okay keep those hands up
everybody okay yeah hands out to
everybody you guys are great okay i love
you guys okay so
when you do something new and great
the natural question is why hasn't it
been done before and you need to answer
that it's not enough to say it was doing
great so there are possible answers like
one is like oh i am just really smart
like and i figured or another one is
like you guys are all just like sheep
and you don't you have clothes mine
that's gonna really
yeah it's gonna really work right okay
maybe it's not that like i don't know
maybe you have new data
you we have data from every day a new
poll know an ad before maybe you have
new technology we were able to fit this
machine learning model and we could find
this thing nobody knew about because
people didn't do it like or i you know
like even new technology can be as
simple as i figured out how to run this
program in python and you know whatever
it is right but like you you could do
that or maybe it is a new idea like you
you didn't someone hadn't thought of
doing things in a certain way it was a
survey question nobody thought nobody
had thought of asking before maybe
there's a new incentive like why nobody
did nobody noticed this before because
we weren't selling this product so
nobody cared right now there's money to
be made and so all of a sudden we we
discovered it right maybe it's
serendipity you know i i was doing
something else and i was making you know
i was doing exploratory data analysis
and this popped out that's that's all
happened to us too right but like there
should there should be or maybe people
were doing it all the time and we didn't
even realize right so there has to be
something that's kind of the flip side
of what you learn from your mistakes
right there's a it sort of goes goes
together
um
now
it's not just political science um i've
made lots of mistakes and statistics too
now and and and and i don't think
i don't have enough time to tell you
about all this of course 40 minutes is
not enough time to tell you about 30
years of mistakes right like how how
could that possibly be
um
i will just say briefly like a mistake
i've made
is to use
point estimates for group level variance
parameters
flat priors and point estimates for
group level variance parameters in
hierarchical models well i know that's
kind of technical which means some of
you have heard of it and some of you
hadn't but like that's life right like
we do a lot of technical work so i've
made technical errors now the error was
not that i did the integral wrong
the error was a kind of lack of
understanding about variability so
here's the story in some of the work
i've talked with you about we use
multi-level
regression and post-stratification to
adjust survey data
and
typically i'd like analyze one data set
at a time like we go all out look at the
2008 election put pre-election polls do
all this and now like i told you i
analyze the data with yair and we fix
the problem and all that and when you're
doing it you're estimating certain hyper
parameters that tell you how much to
partially pull and it's super important
okay
and it all seems to work because the
model you fit fits the data
well then my colleague jeff lacks the
political science department like this
method i gave him some r code and he
started fitting it using a lot on a lot
of different survey questions so it
wasn't a series of elections but it was
it was i think many use either many
questions from the same survey or the
same survey question but from many
different surveys and what he noticed
was that his estimates were jumping all
over the place sometimes he'd fit an mrp
model and it would do a huge amount of
partial pooling
all the way to the model other times it
would do very little it would have a lot
of state level variation so when he made
graphs and maps he'd see things jumping
around and realize that the the amount
of partial pooling is determined by the
group level variance and the group level
variance itself is is hard to estimate
from data it's kind of noisy so really
you should be
accounting for its full posterior
uncertainty also we should be using
prior information to stabilize it and in
retrospect that's kind of obvious and
some people like the epidemiologist
sandra greenland had been saying this
for a long time in fact greenland had
been saying on record for a long time
saying he liked hierarchical models but
he didn't even estimate the group level
variants from the data he just specified
it a priori because he felt that his
operatory guess was better than whatever
noisy estimate you're going to get from
your data which which could be true of
course there's a compromise where you
use a strong prior so i did not realize
i was kind of getting the wrong answer
now where did i go wrong
i went wrong in a few ways partly
there's what we call the bayesian cringe
which is like i
kind of wanted to use the minimal amount
of prior information because i was
embarrassed about using prior
information it's kind of funny to want
to use the minimal amount of prior
information like why do you want to use
less information but that's kind of the
attitude we've been trained in in
statistics so it's partly that partly
about like available software and
like defaults things had worked before
also that i had not tended to look at
the variation in that way when you
analyze one data set at a time you don't
see this it's not just about base so all
of you who do machine learning and
cross-validation it's the same thing
you've got one data set you can
cross-validate no matter how much you
want but by picking the thing that
optimizes cross-validation you have not
you you've optimized for your data set
and yes cross foundation is supposed to
correct for overfitting so i'm not
saying that you're over fitting i'm
saying that the amount of fitting that
you decide to do is itself being fit
and that is itself can be noisy and
people don't realize but
cross-validation is just like a p-value
it's a function of data and it itself is
noisy
um
so
again the big picture
you will make mistakes you have made
mistakes even under optimality you'll
make mistakes because optimality is
you're improving which means your past
work is mistaken right you are making
mistakes all the time what's important
is to learn from them right it's okay to
make the correction but we can't just
we can't just pick the poop off the rug
we have to find the rat right follow the
principles of deming's quality control
that you have to understand what went
wrong in the process
now at this point
i should give you my meta mistakes these
are examples where i made an error and i
didn't learn from it people pointed out
but of course i can't give you such an
example because if i knew about that i
would have so there's selection bias i'm
only showing you the i'm not only
showing you my successes i'm showing you
my errors but i'm not showing you the
errors i didn't know are errors uh
they're they're out there too but i
don't know where they are
um
and let me conclude
with the pluralists dilemma
okay we're all pluralists here right
okay we're all tolerant people i
tolerate everything except intolerance
you know etc well
as a pluralist what i mean by that is
yeah i use bayesian methods they work
for me i respect that other people have
other methods that work for them and i
mean that like i it's not just words
like i really think that like that's
fine that other people i think it's good
that other people are doing other things
at the same time i do think the methods
that i'm using are the best for what i'm
doing at least in my situation or i
wouldn't be using them so it is a kind
of funny thing that like whatever we're
doing
we know that we're making mistakes but
we have to kind of believe in what we're
doing while we're doing it like you have
to commit right you commit to it you
find it your mistake you
so i don't i just want to
conclude with this i don't want you to
feel like everything i'm doing is wrong
so nothing matters and like everything's
as bad as everything else that's that's
not the case no matter what you're doing
you could always do a lot worse i mean
believe me there's always ways of of
doing words and and
you you want to do your best
um
and
[Music]
but we we have to kind of have a plan
ahead of time for how we're going to
learn from our inevitable errors and i
hope that after hearing this you'll can
go back in your own workflow and kind of
be open to where you got things wrong
put yourself in a position where more
people can point errors out to you and
where you can improve your own process
thank you very much
um was that everything i'm doing is
wrong is that the new george box you
know every old models are wrong but some
are useful
uh
yeah
maybe i didn't think about that
connection but but sure yeah i think we
got to make some more of this quote
well it's just frustrating because
i mean we as i said like i'll see other
people
who won't admit their mistakes and
probably i'm not admitting some of my
mistakes too like i just don't see that
right like i but like like i mean like
there's people like um but like there's
people who are making the first order
error which is two which is to not
acknowledge their own errors and learn
from them and that's frustrating i'm
sure i'm making some second-order
mistakes and not acknowledging some
things at least i try but like i i see
the problems with others and it seemed
like it would be more interesting to
give a talk of my own mistakes just talk
about other people's
um before you leave um saying well two
things actually from your talk um one
your xboxing i believe mike malecki was
involved in that and he's here today so
hopefully mike malecki you enjoy hearing
about your work i've always been a fan
of that xbox survey analysis
and then you mentioned you don't have
enough time to talk about 30 years of
mistakes so anytime you want to speak of
the meetup you got it let us know it's
been a few years since you've spoken to
me if you speak every year at this event
we have the meetup you want to speak you
tell me when you're scheduled okay
sounds good awesome
great well
that's everything for you i think
everyone had a wonderful time i saw the
chatter in here people love the beijing
cringe uh people have a lot of other
great comments in here so uh thank you
so much again for your classic slideless
talk
and um i always have fun chatting with
you and hopefully i'll get to see you
again but virtually and in person at
some point
okay talk to you later bye
all right everybody i hope you uh hope
you had a fun time with that before we
head out to our break